you I wonder could you channel travel
your best PT Barnum right and give us a
sort of recap of some of the talented
talented people we've we've met tonight
we've got at your top hat and we're
gonna gain
whoever they are okay they are top top
of the cake so if you go to kind of the
central ring you got it okay you can go
if you go into here yes okay and you
know do any twirly cainy business if you
want to it's a great hat where are we
ladies and gentlemen it is you use
Yvonne the world's greatest talk show
[Applause]
being titillated
[Music]
they say do you have Bennett I'm sad to
leave nauseated
you've got the mysterious achenes
sensational spitballs beat of Zendaya's
wiggling ears yes you through ladies and
gentlemen to the savage beauty of the
motionless Saran asaurus at the
terrifying power of mics Wolverine
grooving to the Godfather of Soul drink
like a fish and pay no attention to his
guests
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen told you really
wanted to see was a man spinning on his
hands
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]